cinco presidentes en los últimos seis
años en Perú un balance que representa
la inestabilidad política en el país
suramericano principalmente por casos de
corrupción
tiene que generarse un consenso no a
veces esta gestiones de transitoria de
estar renunciando cambiando también es
una pérdida de tiempo es decir pero no
va a avanzar tampoco en 2018 Pedro Pablo
kuczynski renunció a su cargo en medio
de la presión del Congreso 20 meses
Después de llegar al sillón presidencial
ahora permanece bajo arresto
domiciliario mientras los fiscales lo
investigan por favorecer contratos con
la constructora brasileña odebrecht
mientras era ministro de economía del ex
presidente Alejandro Toledo está
denunciado por el polémico indulto al ex
presidente Alberto fujimori que
supuestamente concedió a cambio de no
ser destituido asumió el mando su
vicepresidente Martín vizcarra pero en
noviembre de 2021 Perú se enfrentó a una
compleja crisis institucional en el mar
de una álgida convulsión social y
política el resultado tres presidentes
diferentes en menos de una semana
vizcarra fue expulsado por los diputados
tras ser acusado de recibir unos 588 mil
dólares en sobornos de dos empresas
mientras era gobernador Regional de
moquegua en 2014
lo sucedió Manuel Merino quien a tres
días de juramentar en el cargo dimitió
En medio de intensas protestas en el
país fue sustituido por Francisco
sagasti hasta las nuevas elecciones en
las que Pedro Castillo se hizo en el
poder pero su situación no parece ser
tan distinta en un año de gobierno se ha
enfrentado a cinco investigaciones
judiciales y dos mociones de vacancia Y
aunque ha logrado superarlas con éxito
la paciencia se agota entre los peruanos
democracia y no vamos a parar hasta
matar al presidente la corrupción
sistemática ha quedado evidenciada en
Perú en los últimos 30 años seis de los
10 presidentes que el país andino ha
tenido en ese plazo de tiempo están
acusados de corrupción